well into the David Pakman show.
I am Benjamin Dixon filling in for David while
he was away.
There's a lot happening in the news
that we should just get right down to it.
The president of the United States has demonstrated
once again that he does not have the temperament
to serve in the office yesterday and an impromptu
meeting that he had in the Rose Garden.
He demonstrated a level of belligerence and
incoherence, um, that should concern the American
people.
He was infuriated by the fact that Nancy Pelosi
had the nerve to declare that he was involved
in a coverup.
Well, if anyone's been following the loan
this far, you understand.
While that is not an unreasonable statement
from Nancy Pelosi, but it was a statement
that clearly triggered the president of the
United States because this is what he said,
and the Rose Garden, take a listen in.
Things are going well, and I said, let's have
the meeting on infrastructure.
We'll get that done easily.
That's one of the easy ones.
And instead of walking in happily into a meeting,
I walk into, look at people that had just
said that I was doing a cover up.
I don't do cover ups.
Your people know that probably better than
anybody.
I just wanted to let you know that I walked
into the room and I told Senator Schumer,
Speaker Pelosi, I want to do infrastructure.
I want to do it more than you want to do it.
I'd be really good at that.
That's what I do.
But you know what, you can't do it under these
circumstances.
So get these phony investigation's over with.
So mister president, Mister, I don't do cover
ups.
Um, he's using a lot of tactics here that
really, I mean, clearly the president of the
United States is like, clearly he's involved
in something because if the Mueller report
exonerated him to the extent that he declared
it exonerated him, um, he would have released
those documents and completely put an end
to all of this.
The president was meeting with congressional
leaders in order to discuss an infrastructure
plan.
And he was so bothered by what Nancy Pelosi
said, that he basically through the entire
meeting off now, I personally do not believe
that the democrats should give this president
and inch, not as single inch, uh, because
we are engaged in one of the most hyperpartisan
errors in American history.
And by giving the president an inch and giving
them the opportunity to have a, when you are
insuring your at least aiding and abetting
his reelection and dealing with the type of
president who has no respect for institutional
norms, he has zero respect, but respect for
the of law.
He has no respect for checks and balances.
Uh, if you're not going to impeach him, you
sure as hell should not give him anything
to help him get reelected.
So to me, that part is this entire conversation
about an infrastructure bill is political
malpractice and it's irresponsible if you
believed that the president of the United
States is as much of a threat as he is.
But I digress.
I came to talk about today, the president
losing basically what's left of his little
mind in the Rose Garden because he could not
get away essentially holding the American
people hostage, saying that he will not work
on the infrastructure program if the investigations
continue.
I'm not a legal scholar, but someone should
look and see if that itself is a form of obstruction
of justice because he's essentially saying,
either you end this investigation or I'm not
going to do anything for this country.
What's so clever, notwithstanding the fact
that democrats should not give them an edge
on infrastructure, but I digress.
This is what Hillary a night Hillary Clinton.
But Nancy Pelosi had to say about it
for some reason, maybe it was lack of confidence
on his part, that he really couldn't come
match or the greatness of the challenge that
we have.
Uh, didn't, wasn't really respectful of the
[inaudible] of that Congress and the White
House working together.
He just took a pass and it just makes me wonder
why, why he did that.
In any event, I pray for the president of
the United States and I prayed for the United
States of America.
Now I'll have a lot to say about, um, Nancy
Pelosi's last sentence that she's going to
pray for the president and for the United
States of America.
I know she was trying to convey a sense of
somberness and a sense of seriousness about
the situation because the president is acting
in such an erratic fashion dead.
Uh, maybe we do need the intervention of a
divine power, um, but we also have the intervention
of an impeachment proceeding.
But that's not what I'm talking about in this
segment.
Uh, here, here's the problem.
Donald Trump does have an issue.
He seems to be triggered more by, um, by women
then any, anyone else?
Because the, the by far and large, everyone
is declaring that Donald Trump is engaged
in a cover up.
Everyone is speaking to this [inaudible] so
many politics even have Republicans speaking
to this because it is obvious, right?
Again, I said it before, it's so many people
have said, if he was exonerated to the level
with which he claims he was exonerated, he
could end all of the conversations, all the
rumors, all of the, all of the back room questioning.
There's going on right now.
He can ended by releasing the unredacted Mullah
report, but he's not going to do that.
He's behaving, uh, his behavior patterns suggests
that he is seriously trying to, um, to cover
up something or to avoid getting exposed.
I wanted to play a clip from Chuck Schumer,
uh, because, uh, I don't like Nancy Pelosi.
He actually put it into perfect context with
one sentence.
This is what he said, to watch what happened
in the White House would make your jaw drop.
And so that's the problem.
That's, that's, that's the thing that's happening
before our eyes.
We are becoming so numb to the fact that we
literally have an unstable Manchild in the
White House who's petulance as gotten to the
point where he's going to hold the American
people hostage to preserve himself.
I do get the notion of self preservation,
but that's why we have checks and balances.
The Republican Party does not have enough
to marry or backbone to actually stand up
to their dictator in chief.
But we do have eight an opposition party that
has the capacity to do so.
And while they're waiting around and, and
perhaps perhaps the infrastructure, uh, offering
to Donald Trump was merely a bait, a bait
and switch.
Um, but I, I don't think so.
I think the seriousness with which a Nancy
Pelosi was speaking sounds like she was seriously
upset because they couldn't go forward, uh,
with an infrastructure bill.
Uh, but regardless, we have an opposition
party who is not using the, the actual, uh,
institutionalize methods at their disposal
to at least bring forth articles of impeachment,
um, and, and to this president so he can understand
that he is not above the law, but right now
he's operating his, if he's above the law.
I'm, a few minutes ago I spoke about the fact
that I believe Donald Trump does have an issue
with how women speak to him.
There's a clip from a senator Stabenow, um,
that I want you to hear right now.
Um, she's incredibly smart woman and she's
tough.
She will work with him, but she's very savvy
and I, I, I don't think he does well with
strong, smart women.
So they have it.
You have a petulant Manchild who's holding
the United States hostage.
Uh, and he will not move forward with improving
the United States infrastructure unless we
end the investigations who is completely triggered
because it Wohlman of power and influence
and intelligence challenges him.
That is where we are in 2019.
That is who conservatives elected, um, in
2016 and that's who we have to do whatever
we can.
Um, when it comes
to 20, 20, the election in 2020,